Transcriber: Carol Matouk
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Neredeyse 4 yaşındayım.
Okul çağı başlamadan okuma yazmayı söktüm.
Aileme yalvarıyorum.
“Ne olur beni okula başlatın!”
Mahalledeki okulun müdüründen
randevu alındı.
Ben çocuk aklımla bir plan yaptım.
Dedim ki, onu öyle bir etkileyeceğim ki
beni küçük yaşta okula kabul edecek.
Görüşme günü geldi.
Odanın kapısı açıldı,
büyükler içeri girdi.
Ben bir adım geride durdum
ve hop girişimi yaptım.
Herkes bir an şaşırdı ama ben başarıyı
garantilediğimden emindim.
Nitekim bir sonraki sene ilkokul birinci
sınıfın en minik öğrencisi olarak
okula başladım.
Şimdi zamanı biraz ileri saracağım.
Neredeyse 40 yaşındayım.
İzmir Bornova Anadolu Lisesinden ve
Boğaziçi Üniversitesinden dereceyle
mezun oldum.
İlk girdiğim işte sekiz sene çalıştım.
En üst kademelere kadar yükseldim.
Türkiye’ye ilk kez e-kitap ve tablet
bilgisayar teknolojisini
getiren firmayı kurdum.
Kendi markamla yarısından çoğu
kadınlardan oluşan Türkiye’nin ilk akıllı
telefon fabrikasını açtım.
İki sene üst üste Yılın Kadın
Girişimcisi seçildim
ve hep hayalini kurduğum Harvard
Üniversitesinden dünya çapındaki
başarılı girişimciler için dizayn edilmiş
bir programdan kabulüm geldi.
İlk derste sordular.
Kişisel liderlik yolculuğumuz
nasıl başladı?
Önce tam anlamadık.
Kişisel liderlik yolculuğu nedir,
diye sorduk.
Kendinize öncülük ettiğiniz ilk an,
hayatta bir sonraki seviyeye geçmek için
yaptığınız ilk şey, en eski anınız.
En dipten bulup çıkarmalısınız
ki sizin kişisel liderlik
yolculuğumuzun özüne ulaşalım.
Düşündüm ve bu perende
hikâyesini anlattım.
Tam buradan başlayacağız dediler
ve kocaman bir çember çizip
yine burada bitireceğiz.
Ve bu süre içinde bu çemberin
içini dolduracağız.
Program 3 sene sürdü.
Bize iş hayatında işimize yarayacak
ondan emin oldukları;
pazarlama, finans, operasyon, strateji
gibi birçok konuda eğittiler.
Son derste tam diplomayı vermeden
önce de şunu sordular.
Bugüne kadar yaptıklarının bugünden
sonrası için anlamı nedir?
Yani işin ile onun anlamı arasında
bir köprü kurup
üzerinde yürüyerek yaşamına
devam etmen mümkün mü ey girişimci?
Aklıma şirketteki kadın çalışanlarımızla
birlikte katıldığımız
bir atölye çalışması geldi.
Burada amaç kadınların başarılarını
fark ederek
onları yüksek sesle
söylemelerini sağlamaktı.
Başta şunları duyduk:
Yeterince iyi olmuyor.
Yapamıyorum, başaramıyorum.
Fazla yaşlıyım, fazla gencim,
hastayım, engelliyim,
ben yetersizim.
Fakat daha sonra aynı kişiler
şunları söyledi:
Üniversitede parasız kaldığımda
sokakta şarkı söyledim.
Kalacak yerim yokken kimsesiz
hayvanları besledim.
Milli takıma seçilen en genç sporcu oldum.
Komşumuzun kızına keman
çalmayı öğretmiştim,
konservatuvarı kazandı.
Anladım ki hepsi zaten perendelerini
atmıştı bu hayatta.
Evde, işte, okulda, sahnede, sahada
hatta tarlada bile
olağan liderliklerini ilan
etmişti bu kadınlar.
Yalnızca bu gerçeği görünür kılmak için
biraz cesarete ihtiyaçları vardı.
Peki biz her fırsatta korkularımızı
aşmanın tek yolu bilgilenmektir,
mesajını veren bir firma olarak
misyonumuzu
bu yönde kullanabilir miydik?
Şirket yöneticilerimizle bir araya geldik.
Simone de Beauvoir, İkinci Cinsiyet.
Virginia Woolf, Kendine Ait Bir
Oda gibi kitapları okuduk.
Ayn Rand romanlarındaki o kararlı
karakterleri inceledik.
Norma Rae’yı izledik ve Bergen’i izledik.
Sivil toplum kuruluşları neler
yapıyor araştırdık.
Kendi rol modellerimizi belirledik.
En büyük şanslarımızdan biri de
benim kişisel ilham kaynağım,
hayata tutunma enerjisiyle
beni her daim büyülemiş olan
sevgili kız kardeşim
Sibel’in de şirket ortaklarımız arasında
yer almasıydı.
Hep birlikte firmamızın anlam köprüsünü
inşa etmeye başladık.
Bugün Türkiye’nin mobil teknoloji
alanında lider markasıyız.
En büyük yerli akıllı
telefon üreticisiyiz.
Peki bunun anlamı ne Sezen,
diye sorarsanız;
Kızlar Kodlar adı altında
bir proje yapıyoruz.
Tamamen kendi imkanlarımızla finanse
ediyoruz ve meslek liselerindeki binlerce
kız öğrenciye bilim, teknoloji,
mühendislik, sanat ve matematik
alanlarını içeren özel bir
eğitim modülü sunuyoruz.
Onlar kendi geleceklerini kodlasınlar
ve o kapılardan içeriye
kendi perendeleriyle girsinler diye.
Şimdi sizden de bu salonu bir uçak
gibi düşünmenizi rica ediyorum.
Hepimizi aynı yere taşıyor bu uçak.
Tarifeden bir bilet seçip
aldık ve buraya geldik.
Bugüne kadar yaşadıklarımız ve
bildiklerimiz bizi buraya getirdi.
Ama ben biliyorum ki hiçbirimiz
bu uçağın bizi götürdüğü yere
gitmek istemiyoruz.
Biz hepimiz farklı farklı yerlere
gitmek istiyoruz.
O zaman ne yapacağız?
Bu uçaktan atlayacağız.
Paraşütünüz mü yok?
Bugüne kadar sahip olduklarınız sizi o
kadar yüksekten düşerken kurtaramaz mı?
Ama hayatta bir anlam arayışınız var.
Ben niye buradayım, ne için
varım diyorsunuz?
Yaşıyor olmamla yaşamıyor olmam arasında
benim dışımdaki dünya için ne fark var?
İşte o düşünce sizin paraşütünüz.
Bugün bu salondan çıkarken o korkunç,
uçsuz bucaksız boşluğa adımınızı atın.
İçinizde bekleyen benliğiniz ve
dışınızda yaşayan kimliğiniz.
İkisinin arasında bir paraşüt açılacak.
Sizi yavaşça yere indirecek
ve siz üzerinde perendelerinizi atacağınız
o köprüyü inşa etmeye başlayacaksınız.
Bunu kadınlar biraz daha iyi yapacak
çünkü evet kadın ve erkek eşit
ama kadınlar daha eşit.
Teşekkürler.